All right, well, we're no longer
right in the old city of Kraków.
We took the tram, which is over there,
and we came across the Vistula River
and we're looking at, uh, Kazimierz,
if I have it correctly, which is
where the Jewish ghetto is located,
and we're gonna be walking, we're
taking a walking tour this afternoon.
And what's interesting about this is,
you know, you form an impression of
a city because for the first three
days we stayed in the old city.
We thought this is Kraków, uh,
inside the walls of the old city.
And then we begin to realize that
Kraków is actually much larger.
And of course it's much larger because
the central part of Kraków within the
city walls is actually quite small.
So here's another part, Kazimierz.
And I, I think there's more and more to
this city, and again, I bring everything
back to language learning, right?
But so I think of it, you know, when
you're learning a language, you've got
the big picture, the whole language,
which you gradually get bits and pieces
of and where whatever part of it you
have, you think that's the language.
But of course the language
is always much larger.
And, you know, visiting Kraków
here, I bought a book, which is
Historia Krakowa dla kazdego.
So it describes the history of Kraków.
It explains the different
parts of Kraków in Polish.
So this is good for my overall Polish
language, getting the language in me.
I understand 60, 70,
80, 90% of what I read.
I don't worry about
what I don't understand.
I'm still getting the language in me.
I'm getting an impression of Kraków.
I also bought a book on learning polish
for Ukrainians, and I'm going through this
and I'm picking up the bits and pieces
of grammar that I have looked at before.
And every time you look at the
grammar, it's just a, an ingredient.
And I kind of see the whole
process of language learning is...
it's almost like you're, you're mixing a
dough and the dough gets bigger and bigger
as you throw more ingredients into it.
The, the ingredients are the words and
the phrases that you pick up as you're
reading and you're listening and maybe
you're talking to people and sometimes
I, when I talk to people in Polish,
I can't quite manage, and we go back
to English, but it doesn't matter.
They're all bits and pieces that
are fed into this big dough.
And then the visit with the bits
and pieces, the visit to the
grammar, where I don't necessarily
remember it, but it is contributing.
It's contributing to solidifying my grasp
on this overall picture of the language.
And the same way here, we're gonna
travel to different parts of Kraków.
We're gonna talk to people, take the
tram, which is a great experience.
I love taking a local
transit when I'm traveling.
And then we're gonna have a walking
tour, which will be in English.
But this evening we might speak
some Polish, and every so often I
consult my grammar book, which has
the advantage of being in Ukrainian.
So I'm looking at the differences
between Polish and Ukrainian.
And then tomorrow we're taking the train
back to Warsaw and we have a meetup.
And, um, there we are gonna,
I'm gonna speak Polish, uh,
How do you say?
And, uh,
So the important thing is to, in
my conversation, I will make lots
of mistakes, but it's another
engagement with the language.
I will hear what people are saying.
If I have to think about whether
this is correct, is it a Ukrainian
word or a Russian word or a
Czech word or a Polish word?
Is it correct?
Is it the correct tense?
I won't be able to speak, but if
I can start speaking and listening
to people, it's further input.
It's further, further involvement with
the language and gradually slowly, as I
said the other day, the language, if you
get enough opportunity, you will improve.
And I have enough of a hold on
Polish now I can read this book and
understand most of it that if I were
to spend two months in Poland, I
would be speaking quite comfortably.
But of course here with, uh, five days
exposure, I can't speak very comfortably,
but you'll have a chance to hear me
at our meetup on Thursday afternoon.
June the first in front of
the Puro Hotel in Warsaw.
Bye For now.
So here we are in the square, in Warsaw.
Uh, we just went for a walk to get over
our, having spent so much time eating on
a plane and uh, in behind us we have, we
walked a fair distance to get here and
you can see the whole thing behind us.
I can show you there what it looks like.
The old town.
So now we are going to
proceed into the old town.
I spent two months listening and
reading, working up my vocabulary.
I even worked on the plane on my
iPad with my history of Poland and
I've got my vocabulary up to where I
even decided to buy some paper books.
One is, uh, Help Yourself book
and the other is a history or the
Life of Chopin, all in Polish.
I'm gonna read them, it's gonna help me,
but trying to speak has been difficult.
I struggled with my taxi driver.
I struggled on the plane
with the stewardess.
And didn't quite get there, but we'll see.
Couple of days I should improve.